bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france à l'heure où on vient
de le dire plusieurs centres de
vaccination a été vandalisé parmi eux un
qui se trouve dans votre commune
quelles sont les dernières informations
dont vous disposez alors il ya eu une
volonté de que le centre de vaccination
de la cour ne fonctionne plus façon
toute simple en en ayant une action qui
vise à couper l'électricité qui gardent
les vaccins à la bonne température
on avait notamment un groupe électrogène
pour lorsqu'il ya une panne
d'électricité qui devait prendre le
relais et bien y compris le groupe
électrogène a été piraté c'est une
action de deux personnes qui ont la
volonté de s'opposer à la vaccination
par des méthodes qui sont inqualifiables
j'aurais jamais pensé qu'une chose
pareille puisse arriver c'est arrivé et
donc j'ai porté plainte une enquête est
en cours
des vidéos ont été portés donner au
parquet où on voit une personne
volontairement piraté le sentent de de
vaccination alors voilà ça ne nous a pas
empêchés de continuer la vaccination
aujourd'hui et hier le centre de
vaccination a fonctionné grâce à des
élus municipaux qui ont rétabli
immédiatement l'électricité et puis
notre volonté de faire en sorte que la
vaccination se poursuivre
qu'elle soit la plus forte possible
n'est pas entamée du tout bien au
contraire il faut vraiment que les
centres de vaccination soient protégés
par la police protégé par les polices
municipales pour éviter que de tels
dégâts se se soient menées par des
personnes qui sont irresponsables et en
même temps une volonté forte des élus de
faire en sorte qu'on continue la
vaccination
toutes les grandes épidémies ont été
vaincus par une vaccination forte
parfois obligatoire et donc j'ai des
questions qu'il faut se poser
aujourd'hui
alors justement c'est une action
volontaire qui a été menée par des
antilles wachsmuth en est il de la
population justement les habitants dans
votre co peu commune est ce que vous
voulez santé réticents à l'égard de la
vaccination ou au contraire ils ont été
voilà plutôt touché affecté par ce qui
s'est passé très affecté j'ai eu des
messages de soutien peu partout me
disant c'est scandaleux ce qui s'est
fait y compris des gens qui ne sont pas
pour le vaccin et qui ont dit on se
on ne se prête pas de tels agissements
tout ça coûte cher
tout ça prendre pour cible des bâtiments
municipaux des centres de vaccination
face et des problèmes de riche en rendez
compte qu'il ya des pays où il n'y a pas
de vaccin nous on en a et on veut
empêcher de vacciner c'est complètement
idiot sont des minorités agissantes
et je crois que la population
désapprouvent complètement ses
agissements simplement se pose
maintenant une grosse question c'est
qu'il nous faut beaucoup plus de vaccins
pour vacciner beaucoup plus de monde
c'est bien beau de mettre un passani
terre en place mais si demain il n'y a
pas assez de vaccins
on ne pourra pas vaccinés suffisamment
et là j'ai reçu ce matin un mail de la
rs me disant que les premières
vaccinations vont s'arrêter au mois
d'août c'est le contraire on peut pas
voter impasse sanitaire ne pas avoir
suffisamment de vaccins
celle qui arrive en ce moment c'est ce
qui risque d'arriver donc on risque
d'être confronté en tout cas certaines
communes risquent d'être confrontés à un
autre problème celui d'une pénurie de 12
vous parliez du passani terre qui va
justement devenir obligatoire dès demain
dans les endroits
culture ou encore d'activités de loisirs
et puis il sera étendu au fur et à
mesure justement à partir du mois d'août
est ce que la mesure est plutôt bien
accueillie puisque dans ce volet
également du projet de loi anti qu'ovide
il ya aussi cette vaccination
obligatoire pour les soignants vous
parliez tout à l'heure qu'il allait
peut-être falloir se poser la question
sur le risque pas de devenir obligatoire
pour tout le monde
évidemment on est en train de tourner
autour du pot
comment voulez vous qu'un restaurateur
aujourd'hui puissent regarder le pass
annie terre si si la personne qui rentre
à son pass and i ter faire sa cuisine
servir et tout ça il ya des choses qui
sont quasiment impossibles à faire la
vraie question qu'il faut se poser c'est
est ce que dans les vaccins obligatoires
le vaccin contre le coc vie doit rentrer
dans ces vaccins obligatoires
c'est la vraie question les
scientifiques nous disent que si on
n'est pas suffisamment vacciner ce virus
va encore muter va à produire de
nouveaux variants et donc
ayons le courage d'aborder enfin des
vraies questions et pas tourné autour du
pot pas mettre des mesures législatives
qui parfois seront inapplicables
mais se dire est ce que comme pour les
soignants ce vaccin doit être
obligatoire ou pas c'est un vrai débat
parlementaire qu'il va y avoir chez
question et j'ai l'impression qu'on
tourne un peu autour des jeux du pot
voyez quand le président disait il ya il
ya quelques mois je n'oublierai jamais
puis que maintenant ils obligent
aujourd'hui est ce que on a suffisamment
de recul pour dire vu ce qui est en
train de se passer avec ces pandémies
mondiales qui a fait des centaines de
millions de morts des millions de morts
est ce que on ne doit pas passer un
vaccin obligatoire
je sais des vraies questions en tout cas
moi je que je pense profondément
c'est qu' il faudra certainement mettre
là le vaccin du coc vide dans les
vaccins obligatoires je le pense
profondément
merci beaucoup en tout cas martial
bourquin d'avoir répondu à nos questions
ce matin je rappelle que vous êtes père
au ps dont un cours dans le doubs
merci